learned to use django with six different
google apis
in this course from bobby stearman hey
everyone it's bobby from dig coding here
and
in this course i will be walking you
through and showing you how to build
a django app that uses six different
google
apis so let's start with the walkthrough
if you look at my screen
you can see that i've got the app open
already on the sign
in page so if we click on sign up
because we don't currently have a
user account let's put bobby
stearman and we'll have a username this
must be an email
bobby did demo.com
password i will use fred fred1
confirm password fred thread1 we have
also got a
show passwords toggle it converts a
password input to a text input
so you can see they match if i click
sign up when i click sign up
we will be using the recaptcha version 3
software
this is a google product that scores
a form submission and the higher the
score the more likely it is that it's a
real human being that is actually
submitting the form
it's great the fact we've got this
element in the bottom right of the
screen would suggest
that the software is working so let's
sign up
should get a message that says thank you
for signing
up and will then be redirected to the
user account page
the user account the user can then
update their profile with an address
and this is where we're using the google
places api
so it is a predictive so as i type
into the input google will predict the
address
in the country that is predefined in
settings.py
and give you a number of different
addresses that
meet the um the search so let's go with
one two three
and that's coming up with a few
different addresses let's go one two
three victoria street
as i click it it will pre-populate some
hidden
inputs and then i have the option to
update
your profile has been updated okay so
that's one of the apis
the other one is in root so this app
will allow you to put
a starting point so an origin a waypoint
one a waypoint two and a destination
and when we submit this so actually when
we finish the
fourth input here programmatically it
will create a parameter string and
redirect us to a different url and
it will render the map so let's add a
few addresses
so we'll go with one high street
sutton ely
then i'll have another one hi one high
street
hadena ely so this is all around
my local area then we'll go one
high street streatham
ely and then lastly we'll do one
marketplace
ely there we have it
when i click this it will then say right
you have completed all four waypoints
and if you look at the top here it's
creating a fancy
parameter string but the url is map so
it shows the start and destination
longitudinal attitude the duration from
the origin to the destination
the distance between origin and
destination and then it will render a
map
which is brilliant and if i then click
click here for directions it will then
unhide some elements in html
and it will show you every single step
that is required from the
origin to the destination so that is the
application that i've built this is the
one that we're going to go through in
this course i will go through
every single step that is necessary
right from enabling apis at google and
recaptcha
starting a new project building the back
end building the front end and
fully testing the application so
without further ado let's jump into
section one
[Music]
hey everyone it's bobby from dig code in
here and in this segment we will be
setting up two google api keys
these api keys will allow us to interact
with six
google apis the first one we'll be
looking at today
is something called google recapture now
this
is software that stops malicious
software from interacting with your
website so essentially
it keeps the riffraff out and allows
real human beings to submit forms
now you will have come across this
before on other people's websites
you will complete a form and when
submitting that form you'll be presented
with nine images and
asked to select any image that may
contain a bus
or a plane or a motorcycle and if you
select the right images you
can then submit the form that is a
challenge
based form submission and this is
version two
we won't be using version two today
we'll be using version three now this is
not challenge based instead google
scores
each spawn submission against certain
criteria now the higher the score
the higher chance it is that is a real
life human being submitting a form and
not
some malicious software so that's what
we'll be setting up today
and after that we will then go to google
cloud and we'll be setting up another
api key that will allow us to set up
and enable five apis places directions
distance matrix geocoding
and maps javascript so let's jump
straight into it and set up recaptcha
so if you look at my screen it opens up
from google.com recaptcha
about on this page you will find all the
information that you need to find out a
little bit more about recapture
about what it does some use cases and
also the history because it has evolved
over the years
when on this site ensure that you've got
a google account you will need one
click on the v3 admin console
you can see here that i've got six sites
i've been using this for some time and a
lot of my clients
like to use recapture but whether or not
you've got this set up on your machine
already
you do need to follow this process so
you need to click the little plus button
here which
to it which is to create a new site so
let's create a site
and we will call it
google django
tutorial will then click on
recaptcha version three again it says
verify request with a score this is what
we want
version two verifies request with a
challenge
so we'll click on version three and then
you need to add the domain so we're
doing this
in a development environment so it's on
my local machine and we'll be using
django so
the domain in this case is localhost you
don't need to put the port if i spell
that right now i have a
local host and then click
accept and submit
there we have it so it creates a key
and a secret key now working with apis
if you've done this before you will know
but if you haven't i like to look at the
api keys as this
an api key is the equivalent of a
username
an api secret key is an equivalent of a
password
just try to keep them secret because you
don't want people getting hold of your
keys and making calls
fictitiously so let's copy the site key
i like to just dump these in a notepad
so i can use them later i've got one
open here
so we capture underscore key equals and
we'll paste in
the key back to the website
we'll copy the secret key and we'll dump
that
here as well
you can see here i've got another one
called google equals that's the api key
we're
now about to set up that is all we need
to do to set up recaptcha
the rest is done in the code in python
or in this case the django web framework
which we'll be setting up in the next
segment so we'll continue now and we'll
set up the google api key that will
allow us to work with places directions
distance matrix geocoding and
maps javascript what you need to do is
visit
the website cloud.gov
and this is the website you will need a
google account you can see i've got my
icon there
my logo i'm set up as decoding when
set up on google you need to click on
console
and it will take you to your console
home and then you need to
set up a new
project so if you just see look what i
did there
on here just click the pull down list
and then you can set up a new project
and we will call this google
django tutorial
click create
and then when it's finished doing that
you can then select the new oh it's just
doing it um doing its magic it'll only
take a second
okay that's complete so now click the
project that we just set
up
and this is the new google django
tutorial home
you now need to click on apis and
services
when in there you do have the option to
click enable apis and services but first
off we need to click on credentials we
need to set up the api key
click on credentials this will be an
empty blank slate we now need to
click on create credentials this will
allow us to
select different options but the one we
want today is api key
click on the api key there we have it
copy the api key and save that
in the notepad there we have it
and back to the website close
now we haven't named it we can name it
by clicking this little pen here to edit
the api key
and in here you can restrict the api key
to certain ip addresses
change the name which we will this is um
google django
tutorial key and
save by the time you see this tutorial
this
um tutorial will be dead i.e it will be
removed from google so there's no risk
here
that is the key we've set up the key now
we now need to enable
the apis so if we go into the dashboard
again
this option here so plus enable api
services
click there and because maps are the
most popular api service that google
provide
it's right at the top click on view all
17. there's quite a few of them
if you scroll down there's a whole bunch
of different apis here the first one
that we need to look at
is places api
i won't go through what each of them do
specifically
but each of these in your own time click
on them and it gives you an
overview of exactly what they do now
places we'll be using that to
pre-populate addresses when
creating an account in our project so
you'll start typing an address
and it will predict what the address is
that you're looking for and you can just
select it and it pre-fills
all of the address the town the city the
county the postcode and so on and so
forth
and you can always pull from that the
longitudinal attitude which is very very
helpful
so let's click enable that will take a
second
and now that that's completed and
enabled we now need to look for the
directions api
so you can go back to the overview and
click on
enable apis and go back to the main
dashboard but because we've enabled one
now it then gives you some options
of other apis that you can work with so
let's look
look at directions api
click enable
these next api so the directions the
distance the geo coding and the maps
javascript these
are the apis that we're going to use
when
working out different routes and
distances between two geo
points so two longitude and latitudes so
that is the directions api we now need
the distance
matrix
we'll enable that quickly some of them
are quite self-explanatory to be fair
the next one is google geocoding well
lo and behold that allows us to geocode
certain points
so geocoding api will enable this
lastly we need to find the maps
javascript api
and enable that and that will allow us
to write some javascript to actually
make the calls themselves because we
won't be making
api calls from django the calls
themselves will be handled in javascript
so let's click the
maps javascript api
enable there we have it so just to recap
in this segment
we have created two api keys
one of them is with google recaptcha
version three
this will allow us to ensure that real
human beings are submitting forms on
our project and stop the riffraff from
submitting those forms and then we've
created another api on google cloud
and enabled google places google
directions
google distance matrix google geocoding
and google maps javascript apis
this will allow us to have our users
complete
or start typing their address and it
will predict where they live and they
can select an address
and also they can then add two different
points so two locations in any given
country
and our project will then calculate the
root and distance between those points
okay that's the end of this segment
thanks for watching
let's start setting up the project in
the next segment thank you bye-bye
[Music]
hey everyone it's bobby from decoding
here and in this segment i'm going to
show you everything that you need to do
to start building this google api app
so we will be using a python web
framework called django
and we'll be working through how to
start a new project how to create an
app how to configure some settings and
static files such as css
javascript and images and also playing
around with the url conf
now if you're familiar with django you
will know what that all means however if
you're an absolute newbie
i will just show you quickly a little
bit about python and django
and a library that we'll be using which
is virtual env wrapper win in my case
because i'm using a windows machine
so if you look at my screen i've got the
python website open
on their downloads page if you haven't
got python downloaded on your machine
you will need to do it i do have a link
to a video that's at the top of the
screen now that will show you exactly
what you've got to do
to install python and also configure
a library called virtual env wrapper
and that is this page here so it's
uh it's on a repository in pypi.org like
i say look at the video
walk through all of those steps get
python installed in your machine
get virtually nv wrapper installed on
your machine and you'll be good to go
the third tab here is the
djangoproject.com
website so this is django web framework
so it says here django makes it easier
to build web applications more quickly
with this code that is exactly what it
does and that is what attracted me to
django about five or six years ago
i've been using it for quite some time
it's easy to learn the documentation
is absolutely fantastic and they've got
quite a good tutorial on their actual
website all you need to do is click on
the get started with django
link here and away you go but that's
what we'll be
using in today's segment to get started
so
what we'll do we'll start off by opening
up a command prompt
and if you've already set up a virtually
env
wrapper then you can start using certain
commands that's why
i asked you to follow that video because
if you hadn't
uh set up virtual env wrapper then you
wouldn't be able to use the same
commands that i'm going to use today
so what i'll do straight away i will cd
into my development directory
and what i will do is i'll set up a new
virtual
env and the way you do that is
mk virtual env
and then with a space you then name this
env
so we'll call this
the same as the project so we'll go did
django
google api tutorial
okay click enter and that will out do
all of the necessary configuration on
your machine
and it will set up a virtual env
so what i'll do i'll show you quickly
what's that that has just done so if i
click
on my um directories here i go into my
own
so if we're going to bobby which this is
the default configuration it will set up
an env
file in your user directory so you can
see here that i've got envs
and i've just set up did django google
api tutorial
if i open that open lib site packages
these are all of the site packages that
we python will need to work
so these just come straight out of the
box so when you set up a virtual
env this is what you get we will then be
installing django and a few other
libraries and they just get added every
time we pip install a library
it gets added into our virtual env so
that's what we've just done by
adding uh by using make virtual env
go back into our command prompt
and what we'll now do is we will
pip install django
and if i press enter whilst so i
probably glossed over that what but
um the command pip is essentially it's a
standard package manager
and it allows you to install and
maintain packages for python so
we use pip install to install certain
packages from
public repositories such as pypi and
i've just pip installed django
if i go back into my env directory that
i was showing you a moment ago you can
see now that we've got
django package here and within django it
comes
straight out of the box it comes with a
whole bunch of different directories
and models and views and all sorts and
that is essentially
how django works so we'll be making
calls creating models creating views and
forms
and it all interacts with these
directories and files here
so we've now got a virtual environment
all configured and django installed we
can now start a new project
so you need to type django dash
admin and then call start
project and then you need to name the
project so we'll call it exactly the
same as the
development environment or virtual
environment sorry
did django
google api
tutorial
okay that should have done it so if i
now open up my directory again
there we go bobby development and in
here we've got did django google api
tutorial
open that up and this is what comes
straight out of the box we've got a
manage.py
file and then we've got the main conf
directory here and in there you've got
settings urls
uh you've got ascii or whiskey and
you've got an init well a dunder init
file there
so that worked very very well we now
need to
create our first app so django will
allow us to have
numerous apps running within a project
so what we need to do is
open our command prompt back up and we
now need to
cd into did
django
google api tutorial
and now that we've got the project there
we can now access the manage.py
file and that is the manage.py file that
is in the main project
here so we make a call to manage.py
so we say
python
manage.py start app
and we'll call this one main
okay great if i open up my directory
again we now have an app in here called
main
and straight out of the box it comes
with a few files so you have an
empty migrations directory that is
what's used when we're creating models
and you migrate those models to a
database
uh we've got an admin file an apps file
we've got
models file this is where you house all
the models for the project
tests and views we will we'll create one
or two other files but this is what
comes straight out of the box
we're now at the point where we can
start writing some code to do that we
will need
a text editor i use sublime text but
there's
so many different text editors out there
use the one that you like the best
and then you can start coding
so what we'll do we'll open up sublime
text in our
directory that we just created did
django google api tutorial
so there we have it this is the project
in sublime text you can see we've got a
manage.py file here
we've got the main project directory
which we can open up and you can have a
look at these files and then we've got
the main
app that we've got here we will be
focusing our time in settings.py
and urls.py today which is the url comp
file
so we'll open up settings.py first and
foremost
and if i scroll down you've got a whole
bunch of code here that comes straight
out of the box of django this is very
very standard
we do however need to change some of
this code and that's what we're going to
do
right now so at the top of the
settings.py file here you have
frompaflib input path
that is required but we also need
another import
this is import os for operating system
this library allows us to access things
like environment
variables okay and we'll scroll down a
little bit further
if this if we were building this in a
production environment or for a
production
app then i would do something with a
secret key here i would
use a library such as django decouple to
remove sensitive information from the
project
but as we are not doing anything like
that and this is just a tutorial
i will just leave that as it is so if
you scroll down further again with a
loud host that is something more for
production
you've then got installed apps now these
are the installed apps that come
straight out of the box
but we have created an app here called
main
now if you look in apps the name of this
is main okay so that's what we need to
reference in settings.py
so if we enter a couple of times just
add a little bit of white space
just add a string called main and then a
comma
a trailing comma so that is telling
django that the app that we've just
created
is actually included in the project
then if you scroll down a little bit
further we've got middleware
we won't be playing with that here but
there are some libraries that we require
or other applications require and they
do you need you to have some middleware
alterations
root url conf don't need to change that
templates
we won't be changing that wizki
application no change
no change with database either now if i
was to
make this app for a production
application um
i would probably use a database such as
postgresql
but we would just be using the database
that comes straight out of the box and
it's no harm in that at all language
code it defaults to enus
i am in great britain so engb
and then at the bottom here we've got a
variable here called static url
now we will be creating this app and it
will be looking
um fantastic to do that we need to be
using files such as cascading style
sheets so css and javascript so js files
and also images such as logos and things
like that so we do need to configure
static files in settings.py
and how we do that is we add a variable
called static files
underscore does and this is a list
and in here we have we call the os
library that we just imported path
which was also imported at the top of
the page and then we join
and we join the base directory
and we call it static that is the only
change we need to add here for static
files does
the static url remains the same but we
also need one in here called static
root
there we go and this is os.path
dot join dot then bracket
and then this is again base dir
but this one is
static cdn
okay they are the only changes we need
to make to settings.py in regards to
static files
you need these variables for it to work
and serve css and javascript files
to the project to the front end i won't
do any more of a deeper dive than that
we do now need three more variables the
first one will be called
google api key
we'll have that as an empty um string
for now we need
re recapture
call that we capture key again empty and
then we'll have
recapture call this secret key
secret secret secret key there we go
and what i'll do i'll open up the notes
that i made in the last segment
and we need oh it looks like i didn't
save the secret key
but we will get that
we'll save that there
this was the google api key
there we have it and the secret key i'll
have to get from our recaptcha
in a couple of moments in fact let's do
that now
recaptcha and one of the sites that we
would do
it was this one here google django and i
believe if we go into settings
um
keys there we have it right okay we copy
the secret key
go back into our project and we save
that in the recaptcha
secret key there we go that is
settings.py
file complete we don't need to do any
more configuration in there
the next change is in urls.py
and what we need to do in this file is
we need to
after path we need to bring in include
we need from django.com
now when i'm referencing django
directories
i'm quite literally referencing them in
the env file
so go back in here lib
site packages remember when we were
setting up the virtual environment
if we now go into django and
in the project here django.urls
we go into django and go into urls we're
referencing these files here and
functions and classes within these files
that is exactly what we're doing that's
how we're importing them into the
project okay
so from django.com import
settings so we're now importing amongst
other things everything that we've got
in this file here
then from django.com.urls.static
import static
that looks right okay so we need to we
django comes with admin uh an admin page
already
straight out of the box uh but we do
need to add
a uh another path here and that will be
to our main
app url so we haven't uh added that file
yet but we will reference it now
so it's path
and what we need to do is use that
include that we've just imported
and it's main and we'll have a file in
that main
um app called urls
and then we'll use namespace equals
this will be called main
wonderful they're the url patterns that
we need we also need one other setting
in here
for the static files and what we do is
if
debug now we're referencing debug which
is in settings.py at the top
so defaults to true so when when in
development
when debug is true when you have a
problem with your code it'll come up
with the error on the screen
which is very handy but you don't have
the this
you would not have debug set as true in
production so
if it is set to true which it currently
is then we need to
add to the url patterns and how you do
that is
url add equals
static that is the library that we've
got here
and then we want settings
dot static url
and then we want document root
equals settings dot
static root and that
is it so the settings.static url
that's what we set up in the settings.py
file so the static url
and the static route is also this one
here that we set up as well
so we have now set up the settings.py
and the url's comp file correctly and
that should now work
one last thing before we close off this
segment
and that is the we're referencing a url
file
that is not there so if we go into main
new file and we'll call this
urls.py
we will create um the necessary
list that is required for url comp so
we'll say
from django
dot urls import path
from dot so this will be referencing a
views
file which is here
import views so we'll be importing
everything from views
app name so this is what we called um
the app in as a namespace in the url
conf
main and then we want url
patterns equals and that's an empty
list we will add to that in another
section okay so just to recap on what
we've gone through today
we have set up a new django project
we've created a new
app we have adjusted the settings.py
file
we've configured static files in the
settings and url conf
and we then added the url patterns in
the url conf as well
so we are now good to go we are ready to
start coding this application and we'll
be doing that in the next
segment so thanks for watching see you
soon bye
hey everyone it's bobby from decoding
here and in this section we'll be
following on where we left off from the
last one where we started a new django
project
in this section we will be fleshing out
the back end what i mean by that is
we'll be creating some models
or one model actually it'll be a user
profile model that extends the built-in
user model that comes straight out of
the box django the reason we're doing
this is because we want our users to
have the ability to sign up and sign in
and create a profile
this is how we will be using the
recapture api and the google places api
okay we'll also be creating some forms
some views some urls and some mix-ins
for the views
those mixins will essentially help us
make our code look a little bit easier
to read and those mix-ins will be
recyclable we can use them
in other apps as well which is great and
then we'll also be creating the template
directories
so this will be regarded as the back end
in the next section we'll be looking at
the front end which is all about html
files css
so cascading style sheets and javascript
so without further ado let's jump
straight into it you can see
on my screen here that i've got four
tabs open
all of them on docs.jangoproject.com
like i said in the last section
the django documentation is second to
none and
i wanted to just go through this quickly
because we are working with models we're
working with signals
model forms and views so for those that
are absolutely
um well they're newbies at django this
is going to be quite helpful so what is
a model a model is a single definitive
source of information about your data it
contains the essential fields and
behaviors of the data you're storing
generally each model maps to a single
database table so
models translate to database tables like
i said in the last video we'll be using
sql lite um that comes straight out of
the box of django you can upgrade to
something like postgresql
but we're not in this app so when we're
building our user profile model we'll be
using things called
model fields and the most important one
we'll be using char fields and float
fields and things like that but the most
important one that we're using is the
one to one field
which links the user profile to the
built-in user model
which comes straight out of the box of
django and we'll be creating the user
profile using signals so that's models
very very quick top-down viewer models
and by all means have a good read of
these docs pages when you
have a bit more time signals so we'll be
creating a signals.py file
this will be handling the logic of
creating the user profile when a user
is created so we'll be using post save
and a receiver decorator to do that
but i'll show you what that all means
when we get into it
next we've got model forms so we are
creating a model form so this will be a
model form linked directly to the user
profile model
we will also be creating two other forms
these forms will
inherit from some built-in class forms
that django has straight out of the box
one of them is a user creation form and
the other one is an authentication form
these forms uh handle the logic of
signing
up and signing in perfectly so it just
means that we haven't got a handle all
of that logic
we can just call form dot save
and it does all of that in the
background which is great django is all
about getting as much
output with as little input as possible
so if we can get away with using
some built-in models and classes and
forms and things like that we will
so yeah like i say we'll be using the
user creation form to
build a user form and we'll be using the
authentication form to build an
auth form and then we'll be looking at
view so we'll be creating class based
views and function based views i do find
that some tutorials online focus on one
or the other and when you're new to
django it can be quite confusing
especially if you've been focusing your
attention on
function based views class based views
then look a little bit alien so i'm
doing a bit of both in this tutorial
just to help you newbies out there so
let's jump straight into it
um you can see that is that it's where
we left it off yeah okay so if we open
up our command prompt you can see that
i've got my virtual environment fired up
and i'm in the correct file
now we will be working with apis as you
know that's the whole point in this
tutorial
and in django there's a great library
called requests that help us out
massively with api calls so all you need
to do to install it is use the pip
command so
pip install requests
great and that will now be in our env
file that i showed you two videos ago
now what we need to do is start a new
app so we
go python manage dot py start
app and we'll call this users
and that's great if i now look in
sublime text you should now see
a user's directory which is great it's
pretty much blank but we'll start
fleshing out in a second
so the first thing we need to do when we
start a new app is going to sentence.py
and register that app
in the installed apps so users
trailing comma and there are a few other
variables that we need in settings.py
that i forgot about in the last section
so we'll do that now
i will be copying a lot of code for my
other screen in this section because
it will save a lot of time it will make
for a much shorter
section and i will hopefully be able to
hold your attention for a little bit
longer
so as we are using sign up sign out
sign up sign in and sign out logic
we will add some variables in
settings.py
there's a login url so this is where
users will
sign in so we haven't created this url
yet but we will in this section
we've got a login redirect url which is
account this will act as a home page now
there will be a decorator so a login
required decorator on that view
so when somebody visits their home page
or index page it will redirect them to
this sign-in page
but uh that works for this app so i've
kept it in here and lastly we've got a
logout redirect so when somebody signs
out it redirects that user to
sign in so they're the three variables
that we need in settings.py and there's
one last variable before we move on to
the url
conf and it's base country so the
javascript that i've got in this project
uses a country code and it uses that
code when predicting addresses
for the places api so you can change
that to something like
fr for france and other
country codes but it just means that we
can change it in the settings without
having to change it in the javascript
so now we need to go to the url conf
file and
add users to the url pattern so we'll do
that quickly
just copy it down there's no need to
always type it from scratch although it
does help
when learning django but my typing
is terrible so i tend to litter this
uh these apps with typos and it causes a
whole range of issues
so that is all we need to add into the
url comp file that's saved so is
settings so we'll close those
and now what we need to do is go into
main urls and what we'll do we'll copy
this across
to users into a new file we'll change
the app name to users
and we'll save this as urls.py
because we're referencing that in url
conf
py there we have it okay so now we're
good to go we are good to start the
models now
so we are not creating any models in
main main is going to be used for a few
views
such as root and map and users will be
handling all of the authentication logic
so we'll add the models in here
so if i just take my code and i will
copy and i'll quite literally dump it in
here and then walk you through what i'm
doing
so the from django.db import models that
comes straight out of the box and then
we install
sorry we're importing user which is the
built-in user model that i keep talking
about
so you will get used to writing this so
django.contrib.org.models import user
i normally have that in every one of my
views so so you get used to writing that
quite a lot
we then have the user profile which is a
class and it
and you pass through models.model in my
models i generally have a timestamp and
an updated
this allows me to track when a model has
been created so we use the auto add
or sorry auto now add equals true and
the update it is auto now so every time
a profile is created
this will capture the date time and
every time
a profile is updated it will also create
the
um it will keep updating this field with
the new date time
um when it was when it was updated then
we've got user this is the important one
this is the one-to-one field that i was
talking about
you pass through the user model and then
you also have on delete equals
models.cascade
if i move this across so you can read
everything so that means if the user
was deleted then this user profile would
subsequently be deleted as well so
there's no
profile in the database that isn't
linked to an actual user
you can also have something like set
null in there so if the user was deleted
this would still be in the database but
it would be null
next whole bunch of char fields
we've left these or these will be
created as none so null equals two
blankies
equals true because users will add an
address once they've signed up
so we have a chart field for address max
length 100 you have to have that in
there
a max length keyword because otherwise
it just won't work
then we have town county postcode
country longitude and latitude
they're all populated when a form is
submitted from the front end
which we will be looking at shortly
capture score that is the recaptcha
score so
when informat when somebody signs up
we will be using the recaptcha api
to score the submission the higher the
score the more likely it is that is a
real human being
that score is passed through and saved
to this field as a float field
the highest you can get is 1.0 so it
defaults to 0.0
has profile is a boolean field so it's a
simple true false
it defaults to false so when a user
signs up they do not have a profile when
they add an address and longitudinal
latitude
this will then be changed to true lastly
we have an is active boolean
i always have this in my models it's
defaults to true but where it gives you
the option to
change this to false if ever you want to
close a model down and lastly we've got
a done the string
function pass through yourself and we're
returning an f string self.user
okay so that is the model like i say
that translates straight to the database
so when we make migrations in migrate
that will become a database table so
that's our model
we now need to create some forms so if i
click and new file and
save as we'll call this forms dot py
there we have it so we've got three
forms a user form an auth form and a
user profile form
so we're importing a few bits and pieces
here let me make it a bit easier for you
to see
so we're importing model form like i say
we've got a couple of built-in
class forms that um that come straight
out the box use a creation form and
authentication form
again we're importing the built-in user
model and then we're importing form from
django and lastly the user profile from
models that we've just created
so that's all we need in this file we've
then got the
first user form this is inheriting the
user creation form okay so you what you
need to do is create
a few variables so first name
is forms dot character field so there's
a chart field
max length 30. this is exactly
what the field is like in the um
built-in user model
in fact let me start with the user
profile form
it might make a little bit more sense so
this is just a model form but they're
more or less exactly the same
so address you can see here this address
is relates directly to the user profile
address field
and again it's a character field which
is the same as in the model
the max length is 100 that matches what
the max length is
in the model so we try to keep model
forms identical to what they would be
in the model themselves we've got
required true so this field must be
completed for the form to be submitted
and then we use widget a sorry widget
equals form and this is going to be a
hidden input
so the widget in a model form that kind
of
translates through to html elements so
this will create an
hidden input element and it will be
rendered through on the html file
so you could also have text input
you could have password input you could
have a whole range of different things
and you can also pass through things
like classes
and placeholders and things like that
and that's how we can
change the way the form looks on the
front end because uh a very very basic
form from django doesn't look too good
unless you actually add some bits and
pieces
such as classes and ids and names and
then add some css
so this is the user profile form like i
said model form we've got address town
county postcode
country longitudinal attitude they will
be the input elements that will actually
be hidden on the html file
then we've got class meta the model that
we're linking this to is user profile
and then we have a
tuple in fields with all of their field
names
okay so that's the user profile so i'll
start there and then it will
make a little bit more sense when we
look at user form so like i say inherits
from the user creation form
so the first name very much like the
user profile form we're using a char
field max length is 30
because the built-in user model first
name field has a max length of 30. again
required true
and in this widget it's a text input
and we're passing through as an
attribute placeholder
is your first name we're doing the same
for last name except we're changing the
placeholder the username is actually an
email field in this case
so when somebody signs up the username
is an email rather than just a normal
username
and then we've got password1 and
password2
so in this you can see we're actually
we're passing through
a class as well to the attributes it's
because we can then toggle between a
password input and a text input
so there we have it we are then adding a
token field
so this is for the recaptcha token it
will be a hidden input
but that would be capturing the token
when we're processing the form using
recaptcha version three
then we've got meta class model is user
and the fields are
as you can see here they're the same as
what we've got above
then we've got your form the auth form
is a little bit shorter we've got
username and password
email field which with a text input and
a child filled with a password input
and again by inheriting from the
authentication form
that means that when we call form dot
save
it does all of the logic in the
background which is fantastic
so these are all the forms we don't need
to mess around with them anymore that is
um that is
it for this project we don't need any
more forms than that
if i just open that up there the next
thing we need to do really is create the
mixins
so let's go ahead and do that we'll add
them to the main directory
so new file and we'll save that as
mixins.py
again i'll bring it straight from my
other screen here
and paste okay there's some pretty um
one of these is called directions it's a
function that we're going to be using to
make a api call so
these are quite important so we'll go
through these we're bringing a few
through a few things from django one of
them
is a well from the this is from eurlib
dot pass we're importing url in code
this is for
a redirect function that i've got which
i'll go for in a second but you can see
we're importing requests because we'll
be making an api call
and there's a few other bits we've got
json date time we've got format time
span for the directions
api and also json response because we're
making a mix in
for ajax so this is the form errors
uh function that i use this is kind of
the default that i use when i'm
processing forms so if i ever overwrite
the form valid method
there and if there's an error then we
call the form errors
and it essentially returns a string of
all of the errors that you can pass
through to the front end which is quite
handy with ajax
the next one is a function called
recaptcha validation and we pass through
the token
this is the api call to recapture
so the token is passed through from the
front end in the view
and we create a variable called results
and we're doing a post request
to this url okay so it's google.com we
capture api
site verify and then we create a data
dictionary and in that dictionary we
pass through secret as a keyword
and this is the recapture private key
that we've got in our settings
and also the response we pass through as
token that is the api call it's very
very easy
and then we return result.json so we
just sonify the response
and that's what we use when we're
creating the views in a few minutes
this is a great function so what this
does it uses the url in
code but if you pass through parameters
and a url to this function
it essentially returns a string that can
be appended to a url and the string will
look something like
um color equals blue
and size equals large
okay and that that parameter string can
go
you can have a whole range of different
parameters in there but it just means it
can be appended to a url and then when
redirected to that url you can do
something with those
parameters using request.get.get
and we are actually using that in this
app so that's a great little function
that we use
so this is the ajax4 mixin that i've got
and this is kind of the default
mixing that we use although i do
overwrite the form valid function
quite a lot but i've written this for
ajax calls so we can ajaxify form
submissions
this means that on the front end the
html doesn't need to reload
so you submit a form you get the
response and then do something with it
and you can change bits and pieces using
javascript
so i've got this as a way of ajaxifying
django forms
so we've got a form invalid method and
we've got a form valid
and both of them are returning json
responses to the views that we will be
using it
lastly we've got the directions function
passing through args and keyword
arguments
then we've got a whole bunch of
variables here so from the keywords
we're getting lat
a long a and a whole bunch of other
longitudinal latitudes
so lat a and long a that's our
origin so that's where we start in terms
of waypoints
b is where we end up so this is our
destination
and then we've got c and d these are the
waypoints
now i've limited this to two waypoints
so in total you've got
four different destinations but there's
no reason why you can't
have more it's just in this app we've
got two so we've got a start
two waypoints and a destination and
these three variables i use an f string
to create
um strings from these variables here
so that origin will look something like
um
five seven point one seven four
point six yeah that would be the um
string for origin
okay same with destination but with
waypoints you can see we're connecting
with a bar
then we are using requests.get so this
is a get request and we're saving this
in a results variable so we're making a
get request to
this url and then we're passing through
a parameter
dictionary so we pass through origin
password destination
and the waypoints and then lastly the
key so this is the google api key that
we looked at
in the first section okay directions
this is just sonifying the results and
saving it in a new
variable if directions has a status of
okay then we work through this logic
here
and then we return all of this
so it returns origin so the origin is
actually outside of the if statement
there
so it returns them regardless so if it's
okay
we look for the roots and legs keywords
in the json file we won't go through
that yet but
during this one of the sections i might
show you what the json response looks
like
then we um we stipulate a distance a
duration
and a root list here and then we cycle
through
all of the legs and then we keep adding
and adding and adding the distance the
same
duration and that's what we're passing
through to the return statement here
the duration here you can see actually
that we're using
format time span to reformat the
duration into something we can actually
do something with
okay so that is or they are all of the
mixins
we don't need to look at them in any
more detail but we will be using them in
the views
so if we go back to users in views
if i now copy all of my views
so we've got a few views here let me
minimize them
to make it a little bit easier on the
eye like i say i've got some class based
views
and i've got some function based views
these are the class based views this is
inheritance from template view
you've got sign up view is also a class
based view and we're using form view
with the ajax mix in
same with sign in sign out that's just a
function based view and so is profile
view
so it's right mixed bag really and
hopefully you can understand
the different logic we're bringing in a
whole
bunch of bits and pieces from django so
we've got render redirect reverse we are
using the login required decorator so
that stops people that haven't been
authenticated from seeing certain things
in views in bringing in use of the
built-in user model
we're then using login logout and
authenticate these are
fantastic it does all of the
heavy lifting with the authentication of
users we're bringing in settings
settings json response and then these
are the built-in
generic views we've got form view
template view and lastly because we're
using login
required on a class based view we need
to bring in
method decorator we're then bringing in
that's the wrong name that needs to be
tutorial
we're now then bringing in the mixins
that we just built and the forms
okay so let's start quickly with account
view this is the home view that it will
be
and it's inheriting from the template
view so this is a template class view
we need to call the template name or
create template name variable and
stipulate exactly where this
what the where we're going to render
this
view and this is going to be in the
users account.html we haven't created
that html file yet but we will in the
next
video then also the next segment
then what we're doing we're overwriting
the dispatch method
using the method decorator and passing
through login required
so this by this little piece here the
three lines of code here
what that will do that will stop anyone
that hasn't been authenticated from
seeing this
view and if they haven't been
authenticated because we've got
this in settings.py so we've got
log login redirect url
sorry the login url it will be read the
user will be
redirected to this url
so if somebody goes to account and
they're not signed in they will be
redirected to sign in when they sign in
and it works they'll be redirected back
to account okay so that's how that works
so that's the account view uh we've then
got profile view which is function based
view
what we're doing we're creating a couple
of variables we've got user and user
profile from request
the form is the user profile form and we
pass through instance equals user
profile
these two here i will remove and i will
add at the top of the screen so they're
kind of
global and we'll make that capital
so these are the default messages and
results
because we're ajaxifying the forms so
this will be password if ever there's an
error and
that will be shown on the front end so
as we use an ajax to submit the form
we've got if request
dot is ajax then we do something else
it's a get request and then we pass
through context as a context dictionary
so we've got form which is the user
profile form and then we add a couple of
keywords so the first one is google api
key and the second one is base country
from settings okay
and then we return render the profile
html file
and we pass through the context
dictionary that's how you pass through
context
in a function based view slightly
different in a class based view but i'll
come on to that in a second
but if it is ajax then the form
is user profile form and the data equals
the post
data from the request and the instance
is user profile
if the form is valid you save the form
and remember
when i said we were going to add um
when we add a profile we then toggle the
has
profile field to true so that's what
we're doing there so once we've added
the address and longitudinal attitude we
then save has profile as true
and then we save the object again we
pass through success the message is your
profile has been updated
if else if it's not valid we call the
form
error function that we created a moment
ago then we created data dictionary
result equals result and message keyword
is message
and we pass that through back to the
front end as a json response
passing through the data whistle stop
tour of the profile view but
uh that that is essentially how we are
in the um setting up of a profile
against an account
then we've got a sign up view look we've
got ajax mixing
let me just bring this across a little
bit but the ajax mixing and we've also
got the form view
so as it's a form view you need to say
what the template is that we need to
render to
which is a sign up html the form class
is the user form that we built a moment
ago and a successful url can just be a
slash
we are using ajax to submit the form
and depending on the response we get
from the back end we will then redirect
or not
so we won't be using the success url
actually but you do need one because
we're using a form view
again we don't need that i've already
got that at the top of the screen
then what we've got is recaptcha so
remember i said we were looking at we
passed through context in a function
based view like this
yeah as a dictionary in a class-based
view you need to call the get context
data method
and then once you've called that you
then can add a keyword to context and
return context
so we're adding recaptcha site key to
the context
and that is the key in settings
and then we overwrite the form valid the
form valid method
in the ajax mixing and we do that
because we need some
new logic here because we're dealing
with recaptcha so
we we call this if self.request is ajax
so if this is an ajax call then what we
do is we get the token from the
clean data from the form so this is the
hidden input that we had in the form
then we called a recaptcha validation
function that we
created in mixins and we passed through
that token okay
so depending on the response if it is a
success
then we sign that user up okay so we
save the form remember it's uh
the form has uh the user creation form
uh which does all of the heavy lifting
like i say so we just need to save the
form and it creates that user and user
profile with the signal
we save the email so we save the
username to the email field because
we use an email as a username and we
save the profile
the object then with user profile
we save the capture score to the user
profile capture score field and then we
save the user profile
so that's what we do lastly we call
login okay
so with login you pass through a request
you pass through the object which is
um the user built in user model
and then this isn't necessary if you're
using
something like all off where you've got
multiple back ends
then you need to stipulate what back end
you're using but you can have that in
there anyway it doesn't really matter
the result is success and the message is
thank you for signing up we create a
date addiction where you pass it through
adjacent response
okay so that is the sign up view
sign in view again ajax form view form
view
again we do all of this logic like we
did above it's just slightly different
because the templates are slightly
different
we haven't we don't need to pass any
context through but we do need to
overwrite the form valid so again very
similar to above
just we've got the username and the
password and what we need to do
is um call user equals authenticate and
then we
authenticate that user if user is not
none
we log them in okay and if not we then
call the form
error so we don't necessarily need this
because we are using the
authentication form but because we are
also calling the full marriage i've just
left that in there
it's probably surplus to requirements to
be fair but uh that is the sign in view
and lastly we've got sign out view which
is a function based view
and all it's doing is logging out and
put and we
pass through your request and then once
it's logged out you redirect
to the sign in page they are our views
i am trying to fly through these
um but be as detailed as i can so you
actually understand the logic of what
i've done here
like i say i've just identified in the
sign of you that it doesn't necessarily
need to look like that you could
technically technically you could just
use the ajax form
mix in and it will save the form but one
of the main reasons is that we can have
this success message
um because the um the mix-ins if you
look on the
mixing here there is no message it's
very very basic
okay next at a minute we've got
bugger all in there but what we need to
do is
copy and paste
all of this so we're importing the views
that we just created the app name is
users and in the url
patterns remember account is home
so it's a class based view so you need
to call the as view method
so it's views.account account view dot
as view
you don't need to do that for profile
because it's a function based view
but um normally and i don't know why
i've done that but we'll go profile
and unscore view normally on a function
based view i
um do this and i think that is the
normal syntax
so go back into view we'll change that
else it won't like it
so go back into urls and i'll save that
so the profile
views dot profile view you don't need to
call as view because it is a function
based view and the name is profile we've
got to sign up sign in and sign out
these are two both class based and this
is function based so that's the syntax
that you need okay
so if it's a class based view you call
it as view
if there's a function based view you
don't need to and they are
our urls and we're already pulling from
these urls in the url conf
with this line here okay
i've just noticed that i've forgotten
something fundamental so we
need a signals py file so
new file save as
this will be signals.py
and what we need in here is
all of this so we're importing post save
from signals
the user model we need a receiver
decorator
and we also need the user profile that
we've created in models
so the receiver decorator needs post
save and the sender
to do anything so the sender is user in
this case so what we're listening for is
a signal from the user model
and the function is create profile we
pass through the sender
which is user the instance of the user
created and keyword arguments if created
so if
user is created we then create a user
profile
and the user because it's a one-to-one
field equals instance
okay that's what we put in signals but
to make sure that actually fires up when
we fire the
local server up we need to go into apps
and def ready password self
and we import users
dot signals
and that's all we need to do so this
these two lines of code
will be responsible for firing up this
signal
okay and now we need to focus on the
main app so if i go into
here and look at the urls we'll do it
ask about face
we do the urls first so main is just
responsible for
two urls one of them is root this is
where you will be
adding the different addresses for your
directions
and when you complete the fourth
direction it then
picks up all four redirections you
redirects you to this url which is map
okay so then we'll go to view
okay so
we're just looking at render redirect
and reverse we're importing
settings and that is wrong
there we go and we just need directions
remember that mixing we created earlier
well that is what we're bringing in here
and then we've got a function based view
both of them are function based views so
def root and we create a context
dictionary here we pass that through
to the root html file
very very basic view it's not doing too
much
most of it will be or most of the heavy
lifting on that view will be done
using the api and the javascript which
we'll come on to in the next section
so then the last view that we're going
to look at today is
map this is where we have our map and
root
directions rendered so this is the the
fun bit
so we will be passing through
a whole bunch of parameters so if you
remember in our mixing
if you remember in our mixing we've got
this the redirect params
that will be responsible for creating a
parameter string
that will be passed through to the main
view and
it will contain all of these so it will
contain
keywords such as lat a long a lat b long
b
and so on and so forth we know that la a
and
long a are both their origin the
starting point
b is the destination and c and d are the
waypoints okay we know that because
that's how we created up directions
the function that is also in mixing so
we say that
if there is a lat a that b that's c in
that d
then do this call of directions okay
else so if if somebody tries to visit
maps without those parameter strings
it would just redirect them to main
route so it'll go back to the route and
say do it again
okay but if there is a lat a b c and d
it will try
to call directions from the mixing and
it just passes through the la
a la b you know and so on and so forth
okay
and that's what we built into mix-ins if
you remember there we go so these are
the keyword arguments so this is what
we're passing through from the view
let a long a lot b b c
c d d okay
and that is the if that is the else so
this will redirect but if it doesn't
redirect then it will create a
context dictionary there's a lot going
on here we're passing through the api
key
base count uh country this is all
required for the api call that we're
going to make and we'll all become clear
when we start writing the javascript
passes through all of the longitudinal
attitude and so on and so forth
plus it passes through the origin the
destination and the directions
because we need that to render onto the
html file which is
map.hdml
so they are the um
all of the views they are the urls the
models and so on and so forth
that just leaves us with creating a
template
directory so we haven't got anything in
there there's a couple of ways of doing
this
now if you're creating reusable apps
i.e those sort of apps that you can um
you can upload onto pypi so that other
people can actually
install them then it's it's probably
best for you to have templates in the
actual app
so it's all contained in one but as
we're not doing that you don't need to
do that at all all you need to do is add
a directory in here
in the main directory which will be new
folder
we'll call this templates
and all we will need is a new
directory in there for users
and we'll need one in there for main
so when we're referencing main slash
map.html we'll be looking for
a file in here if i save this
as map dot
html
this view will be looking in main for
map html so be looking for that
that's how that works the only thing is
this project isn't geared up to look for
templates in that directory
we need to go into settings.py and tell
it where to look
you do that by going to templates you're
going to dares
and all you need to do because it's in
the main directory you need to put
templates and that
is it okay
i hope that that was a good balance of
firing through everything so you can get
through it nice and quickly without
um skipping over kind of some
fundamental stuff
we've got covered a lot of ground we
have started a new
user app we've built a model some
model forms some views some urls you
know we've
reconfigured settings the url conf we've
configured templates
we've covered a lot of ground but that
is it in terms of the back end
in terms of django that's this app is
complete
it won't work however because we haven't
got anything
such as css html or javascript that's
what we're looking at in the next
section
but one thing actually i've just noticed
also is that in our settings.py file
we're referencing a directory that's not
there for static
now that's an easy fix
new folder and we'll just call this
static
great that is our static directory and
that is what this
is referring to okay good that is the
end of this section i hope you've
enjoyed it
and i look forward to going through the
next few bits and pieces
thank you and goodbye
[Music]
hey everyone it's bobby from dick coding
here and in this section we'll be
following on from where we left off in
the last one where we
fleshed out the back end of this django
project in this section
we will be playing with the front end so
we'll be creating html files css
javascript jquery ajax and
google apis so this is the
fun bit of the project actually because
this is where all kinds of strings
it gets strung together so without
further ado let's jump straight into it
if you look on the screen here i'm open
on
the django docs for template tags now i
have created a video on my decoding
channel
that does a deep dive on tank template
tags and filters
so if you want to understand what they
are then by all means have a look at
that
rather than me going through this page
but we'll be working with a lot of
template tags today
so have a read and have a watch and then
come back i guess but let's go jump
straight into the sublime text
this is the project where we left off on
the last section
you can see here that we created a
static directory
and a templates directory this is what
the last couple of two or three minutes
of the last section this is what we did
and we've got main and we've got users
in there so what we'll do now
is we will create the first html file
and that needs to be in templates as a
base it's a new file and we'll call this
save as base.html
okay and i'm not going to write this
from scratch because it will take
forever
i didn't design this app to be kind of
uh basic
you know it looks pretty it actually
works you could it resizes is responsive
so there's a lot going on
so what i'll do i'll quite simply copy
copy and paste it all across and i'll
walk you through what i'm doing
let's move this over here a little bit
so
first and foremost there's a template
tag here which says
load static this is a template tag that
allows us to access our static files
now static files as configured in
settings.pyle
py are all going to be in this directory
here as we're in development
however if we're in production then you
would set up static files in a slightly
different way and maybe have them
served up to the project via an s3
bucket or something like that or digital
ocean spaces
so this load static template tag allows
us to access files in static directory
uh we've got some basic html here i'm
not going to do a deep dive at all
but we've got um this is the main the
all
these links here these are my fonts so
we use courier prime at decoding
we've then got a style sheet that we're
referencing main.css we'll be playing
around with that in a second
so this bit here is calling a cdn
essentially and this is for toaster so
we'll be using toaster alerts to display
messages from the back end
so if you remember in views we've got
this message
defaults to there was an error and the
result is error well that's going to
show a red toaster message
if you don't know what it is if i go
back into my browser i've got toaster
examples here
so this is a success top right but we
can have a bottom right which i believe
i've got in this project
show toast there you go and it can you
can have whatever you like in there you
can
test show toast there you go test okay
so that's what we're using in this
project
go back into the uh project here go back
into base
so that's the css that's required for
toaster and we always stick that in the
head
you've then got block extend head so we
use a block template tag
okay so this allows us to extend the
head script
so i've got some notes in here as well
body so
we've then got nav we're using an
include template tag
we haven't even created this yet so i'll
do that now quickly
so new folder and this needs to be
called
partials
and in partials we need a new file
called nav html
okay so that one i'll be picking up from
this one here
go back in the base and so this include
template tag
rather than having um all of the code
that's going to be in nav html you use
the include and it kind of interjects
that html element into it
then we've got this div so don't worry
about these too much
the classes i will be creating some css
because i've named these specifically in
a certain way so that it renders
nicely and looks great on the front end
if you remember when we looked through
the um
the demo of the app it looks pretty good
right so
we've then got include partials logo
hate logo html
so let's create that cr i can't talk
today let's create that quickly
new file and we'll save that
as logo.html
i'll bring across that code in a second
anyway
save and then we've got a block so these
blocks allow us to extend certain parts
of this base in other templates it'll
make more sense in a second and it's
called content so we've got block
extend head block content and we've got
another one here
extend footer so these are our footer
scripts
so first and foremost we're using
something called jquery
this is a i believe the most popular
javascript
library uh and it allows us to access
things such as
ajax so we can make an asynchronous form
submission for instance we submit the
form
and we get the response and nothing
reloads on the html page
at all it's all done asynchronously so
that's why we need
jquery but you can get this code from
code.jquery.com and get the most recent
version
then we've got the toaster javascript
which is all this again you can get
visit this
cdnjs.com and get the latest version
from there
then we've got a block for extender
footer again it allows us to extend this
part of this html into another
document and then lastly we're
referencing main.js
so there's two files in static that we
do need
so new file and we'll save this
as main dot js
that'll be a javascript file
i'm going to save as again and we'll
call this main
oh no we won't new file
save as this will be main
dot css
so there we have it we've now got the
main css and main javascript so we're
referencing them in base html
so even if we were to not put anything
in those files we're not going to come
across
any errors and then we close off the
body in html so that is base html we
don't need to
do anything else in that file all we now
need to do is create the documents that
will be extending these blocks
okay so the first one we'll look at is
the index
or in this case it will be account which
is in users
so we'll create a new file let's be
save as we'll call this
account.html in fact
we'll save as we need another one here
in here called profile
save as another one in here called sign
in as underscore
save as another one called sign
out and whilst i'm at it i will also
do the map so templates going to main
i've already got map in there and we'll
have roots
save good let me close some of these
down we've got far too much going on up
here
it's a real bad habit i have
there we go right so then what we'll do
we'll look at account
okay so this is our home page
so i will copy
and i'll paste this across so it extends
the base dot html so it's extending this
okay
that's another template tag that django
has
load static okay so we now access static
again
we're not adding it that doesn't
necessarily need to be there but it's
not hurting anyone so
we'll add that if i wanted to add a
script in there for instance
yeah so would add script you could then
add something in there
but we're not so we won't but this is a
block
um content so this is the content
that will be injected if you like into
this section here okay so block content
so block content block content okay
so we'll just save this so we've got h3
tag
as you know it's a django google api
course and this is the user account
and then we've got a div which is
container so we'll be referencing these
classes in the css
but i'm not going to dwell too much on
css this
is more about the apis than the
javascript so we'll quickly do that in a
second
and then we've got h4 tags so user
account details and then we've got a
table
okay and in that table we've got a table
head it's got
a head and then black i'm sorry a field
and then a blank field so there's no
header there at all
then we've got a table body and then for
each row so we've got
username request dot user dot username
so django uses something called context
processes to always pass through request
to html so you can always access request
therefore you can always access
request.user
and a field such as user.username you
can access things like in our case would
be request.user.userprofile.address
things like that make queries such as if
request.user.is authenticated
so it's really really handy that context
processor is used
more than anything else the next row
we've got name
and then we've got so we're using a
filter so this is a template filter
request.user.firstname title so this
will put a capital letter at the front
of the
um the name and then space last name so
first name last name
and then we're doing an if statement
here so an if else
so if
request.user.userprofile.haspprofile
so if they've added an address
display this which is a table row
details our address
then it will show address town county
postcode
else so if they haven't so if they're
just newly signed
up then it will show user profile and it
will have an a tag with a href
and a link so we're using the url
template tag to users
profile so it will just be a hyperlink
where they can click it and it will take
it to the profile
so they can then select their address so
this is why i've got that has profile
in as a field on the user profile model
that's it that's all what's going on in
account not much
else so let's build out the profile
paste and save there's a bit more going
on in this again it extends base
got load static then we've got the block
content so again
this is the block then we've got extend
footer so if we remember in base we've
got this extent
extend footer here the main js is always
the last javascript that we load that's
just the way
i do it that means that anything above
this i can reference
so i can definitively know that any ajax
i'm
writing in main.js it will work because
jquery is loaded first okay and the
block extends footer
this is all loaded before main.js so i
can actually reference any
variables that are stated in the extend
footer block so in profile we've got
extend footer
and then we've got a script so this is a
javascript script and we're creating two
variables
one variable is google api key if you
remember we're passing this through
let me remind you profile view
in context we're passing google api key
and base country
through to the context that's how we're
accessing it here
okay so we'll create a javascript
variable so we can access this
in the main.js file we'll call it google
api key
and we are and we're using the safe
filter
so it will just create a string of that
api key
same goes for base country the next
script
is a file called googleplaces.js we
haven't got that yet
so we will create that now so it's
google places
save as
api.js
great go back in the profile so that's
now referencing a file that is there
that will work
go into the container so this is the
main main bits and pieces
so we've got an if statement here with
an else so if the
request.user.userprofile has profile
show all of this else add address
okay end if
okay so we have got um
end if okay just trying to figure out
what i've done here so this is input
google address right okay so this here
is that is the main input for the google
places api
so this input here is the input where
the user starts typing an address
and google api predicts what they're
trying to type and then it
returns the address they select it when
they select it it then populates all of
these inputs here which i'll show you
what i'm doing in a second let me just
cover this off first
so if they have a profile it will
display the profile
okay so it'll display the address and
then it will have
a change address and then it will have
or else it will have add an address
so if it changes the address you can
then change the address to the new one
you'll type away and any address you
select it will change
if not you just add an address so this
is the main input you can see here we've
got name google address
id is id google address we will be
referencing them
in the google a places api
just for reference then we've got a form
and then that is the end of that really
so we'll look at this form so the ideas
profile form we will be
creating an ajax call using
jquery on that so that is the name we'll
be referencing profile form
the method is post and the action is
forward slash profile so that's
essentially the url we will be firing
the ajax call to
which is uh if we look in
the urls it's here so it's the profile
is the name
and that is assigned to views.profile
view
okay so let's look at a form
so as it's a form we need to use another
template tag and this will add a hidden
input with a csrf token
so csrf token means cross site request
forgery token and it's a token that's
applied to a form so when you submit the
form it knows that it is actually you
doing it and no
um toe rag doing it from somewhere else
and what we're then doing is we're
creating these labels
um so address is uh actually no these
are hidden right so
the class is hidden l and it's hidden
okay and the reason we're doing this is
because in the javascript in the main.js
we write in a function
to display these hidden elements
when we select an address and this is
why we're doing it so the label itself
is hidden
class hidden l and it's hidden and
form dot address if you remember that is
a hidden input so we're going to forms
hidden input form sorry hidden input
so all of these are hidden so they will
be rendered as hidden inputs
in here as is the label so label
and input hidden then you got town
county
postcode country longitude latitude none
of these will be displayed
until the user selects the address and
then we've got a javascript function
that will unhide all of these elements
the button to submit is disabled so you
can't
submit the form until an address has
been selected
and we add an id to this profile button
because we reference that and we
programmatically click it when the
address has been selected
okay so that's the profile html next
let's look at
sign in okay let me get my notes and
sign in copy across
paste extends base same as we load
static
always the same then we've got the block
content
okay not much else going on in this but
we've got a h3 tag and then we've got
the container here
so this again is a form yeah so again
cso
csrf token the id sign in form
post sign in okay so i'm having the id
the method and the action
always in the form as attributes that
way
we can when we're making the call in the
javascript it's a lot easier to
understand what's going on label again
right so with creating a label the
difference is this isn't hidden
and a form.username because we're using
a form view
you access the form from the form object
so it's form.username and that's the
the input so if you look at forms
username password fields username
password that's how we reference the
number in
sign in okay so that's why we've got
form.usernameform.password
then we've got label so this
is show password so if you remember in
the
forms we have got a class
let me show you class password okay
so what i'm doing in sign in is
on click so this is a little check box
right so the css will make it
look pretty but essentially it's a check
box so if it's unchecked
it will be a password input but when
they click it
it becomes checked for starters
and it calls a function called show
password or show keyword
now this function i'm going to write in
the main javascript file
and that will essentially swap that
password input to a text input
so you can actually see the password
okay which is quite standing on
on websites and then the button is
submit and sign in okay
nice and easy next one sign out
sorry sign up no that should be sign up
we know
there we go sign up so we will copy
and we will paste a little bit more
going on in this one so extending base
html when we're loading static
pretty standard stuff and this one we
are extending the head we'll come back
to that in a second
we've got block tag we've got a form
and we're extending the footer so if you
remember in the sign up view
we're playing around with the contacts
using the get context data method
and we're passing through a recaptcha
site key okay which is the recapture
public key
and we're creating a variable recaptcha
site key that we can reference in the
javascript that we haven't written yet
okay the form is pretty standard similar
to what we've just done
csrf token then we've got the first name
last name username password1 password2
difference is we've got token in this
one so the token
if you remember in the forms we added as
a hidden input
and that is how we're going to be
handling the recaptcha token
okay so that's a hidden input you won't
see that when it's rendered
then we've got this little checkbox box
to show the password again and a sign up
submit button okay so that is the form
and what we've got at the top here is
a script so this is the
um source is the url https google.com we
capture
api.js javascript so this is the
javascript
that we're putting straight from google
and we're passing through
the um our recaptcha site key so that's
how it knows that it's
us making the call to recapture
because the site key that we set up when
we set up recapture in the first section
um we're linking it to that api key
so and that's the javascript call that's
the script where we sit in the extend
head
so essentially this script being in that
extend head is the equivalent of it
being in
well it'll be there but without the head
so imagine imagine that okay
so that's what we're doing by adding
that to the extend head
so that's the javascript and that's the
block that's content
happy days that is the sign up page so
now let's look at the main
map
actually let's look at the partials
quickly copy
partials okay so this is the logo so
it's just an a tag
essentially and if i save that so if you
click on the logo it will take you to
user's account which is the home page
and it's referencing i think it's the
first time you've seen this in this
tutorial
load static so this is how you reference
the static
when you load static you can then use
the static template tag
if you didn't load it it wouldn't work
and we're looking in branding so in
static
new folder branding
and it's trying to find a gif which is a
did logo gif we'll add that in a second
uh which won't be a problem at all and
then we will add the nav i've got a lot
of if statements in this
nothing too fancy to be fair it's got an
if statement if else so if the
request.user is authenticated so if
they're signed in
they will see this nav if they're not
they will see this nav
okay so let's look if so when you first
enter the site if you're not
signed in you'll have if sign in in path
so um if the url is
sign in then this will sign in will be
active
okay so on the side now that will be
glowing up purple if not it will be
blank
if it's sign up it will be glowing up
purple if not blank that's what these if
statements are doing it's just basically
showing whether or not it's active or
not
if they are authenticated and the
request path
equals equal slash which is home again
active
if not same goes for profile routes
map okay so it just shows different um
different navigations to be fair
let's close that let's close that let's
close sign up
sign in profile and account we'll keep
base open
we'll close that and now we will do
map so copy it's going to map
we'll paste this a lot more going on in
this
save okay so map extends the base html
load static
in this one again we're passing through
recaptcha
so we'll capture site key okay and
then to be fair we probably don't need
to that's probably a hangover but i'll
leave it in there
because we're not making a recapture
call in map we're only making it in
uh sign up okay so we've then got a h3
tag and we've got a container so what's
going on here um we've got
i'm going uh do you know what let's do
root first
let's do root first
okay this is ro yeah so root is the um
the url where we add
the longitudinal attitude for the origin
the waypoints and the destination
and map is what's rendered so that's the
last point in time actually so
let me look at root quickly
so i've just pasted that all in there
extends base load static and then again
we've got recaptcha we don't need that
i'm sure i can remove that but i'm not
going to because
i haven't tested it and i know that it
works in in the other project
but we're not technically making a
recapture um call so
i'm you know what i'm certain that
doesn't need to be enough
okay then we've got the h3 tag
and then we've got uh the inputs so
this is the same as account and no
profile so in profile if you remember we
had this input here
and we called it id google address
difference here
in root is that we've got four
so if you look here i've got id google
address dash a
dash b so remember start and end
don't ask me why i didn't go abcd it
seemed logical at the time but looking
back i probably should
should have gone a b c and d instead of
going a and b
that is point a b is the destination and
the way points are c and d
i guess because uh you can do more
waypoints that would be c
d e f g that way but hey look the logic
was there when i was building it
so these are the inputs so as you type
in here
it will predict the address as you type
in c it will predict the address and so
on and so forth
and when you select each of them
it then adds the geo coordinates the
longitude and latitude to
each of these hidden inputs here so this
class is geo
id is la a long a okay and then it adds
a value i'll be using javascript to add
that value
yeah we didn't need that um
recapture at the top of the screen
because not even passing through the um
recapture key so i can remove that from
map as well let's move let's remove that
there's no point in it being there so
save back to root so this is the extend
footer so we've got a script
here a couple of variables google api
key in the base country
and also we are then referencing the
google places waypoints.js
because in this we have two so let's
add another one and
save as and this was
google waypoints
was it api.js waypoints api
let's have a look that's probably wrong
google places waypoints
waypoints and then if we delete that
there we have it we've now got that file
so that's reference in a file that is
actually there
okay so now we'll look at the final html
document which
is map.html so if we
go in here i did paste this a moment ago
anyway
you can see that we've got quite a lot
going on this is where we
render the map from google so
let's look at let's look at the footer
first so we're passing through if you
look at the map
view in the context we're passing
through all of this
okay so we're passing through the key
the base country lap the long the da da
da da da da
in maps we are getting all of those and
we're creating
in this case we're creating a string
we're always using the safe filter
um else javascript doesn't like it and
then you've got we're creating variables
a lot long a and then b c d origin
destination and directions we're going
to
need those in the google places api and
google places waypoints
and also google maps
javascript which we haven't created yet
so new file save as
google maps dot js
okay so we'll be needing all of that in
google maps
okay then got another h3 tag
and uh we'll we'll focus on this first
before we look at the table in the
container so this is the map container
this is the map route so
we will be referenced in this id map
route because
uh google the the javascripts in the
google
js files that we're just creating they
will essentially be
rendering the maps and everything else
all of the routing and stuff
into this element called the map route
and we'll be referencing map free in the
javascript
then if we look at the container we've
got another table
so we've got the start the destination
the duration and the distance that's
kind of the header of the table
and we're pulling from directions origin
directions destination so that is what
comes through when we call
if you remember when we've got
directions here so we're passing
directions through
to the context and that is essentially a
dictionary so we're referencing
uh keywords in that dictionary
directions such as origin
destination duration and distance and
that's what's being rendered here
then we've got directions and we've got
id
dir toggle so this is javascript void
href and then we've got on click
directions toggle so this is how you
you view the directions it doesn't show
the directions and tissue until you
toggle it
okay so that's just a little little link
that we've got there
and then we've got another table so
we've got table head directions distance
duration
and this is where it renders the whole
route
so for each leg in directions.root
we do a for loop and a counter and then
we do
we do this for loop here with dist
duration text we're creating those
variables that we can reference down
here
and they are in leg dot steps we're
going to we're doing a for loop in leg
dot steps
creating three variables distance is
there duration
is there and text safe is there
because that is raw html that comes
through from
google and that's why we need safe
because it will actually render that
html
properly in the website
and that's it that is maps okay the next
thing we need to do they're all our html
is complete we now need to add some css
uh which will do i am not going to waste
your time on css this app
tutorial was all about showing you
google apis and django
css is not an afterthought it's very
very important it makes it look
fantastic
but you know we could spend an hour
going through css which isn't
necessarily important
but you can see i'm referencing body
um i'm saying that the font family for
this particular file is courier prime
which is
correct uh the map root element
so this is um what we just looked at
here
where is it so map root so we're
referencing different elements in each
of the html files
so we've got map container so i've
probably got one for if i search
there you go body html map container
height 100
i didn't need to search for that it was
right at the top we then got logo we've
got the side nav so this tells you
this shows you what the sign nav will
look like then we've got some
some media screens so it depends on how
big the screen is is how it gets
rendered
these are how the inputs look so text
input and email
password input we've got select text
area
this is how it's rendered this is how it
looks we've got width 100
padding 12 so on and so forth okay so
we don't need to waste our time on this
which so we won't
the next thing is the main javascript
so if i go into main paste this
right at the bottom here we've got code
straight from django this
is a javascript function to get the csrf
token from a cookie
to and then it passes that through with
an ajax call
this is a way a a workaround to make
sure that the right csrf token is passed
through
when a form is submitted okay so it's
very important you have that in your
javascript file
when you're submitting ajax so let's go
right at the top of the file let's
open it up a little bit right directions
toggle if you remember in maps
i saw that directions toggle somewhere
here you go so we've got a little link
here
um and it says you click here to open up
the route basically so you can see the
route for the map
and it's on click you call direction
toggle and all it does
is it opens up it removes the hidden
attribute
and adds a new element so we don't need
to necessarily go through the javascript
itself but
that is what it's doing when you click
that toggle it's calling this javascript
function and
it's fading in the directions table
else you fade out so you either display
it
or you hide it one or the other
show alert this is for toaster
so we call show alert every time we make
an ajax call
and it depends on if it's a success or
uh if there's a redirect for instance we
pass through all of these uh keywords
all of these um keywords here and if
there's a redirect url then we call
this toaster else we call
this toaster so what it's doing is
picking up the title so in that case it
could be
success the message could be thanks for
signing in
and it's creating a toaster so if you
look
at the examples again it's creating a
toaster based on all of this
so if we add a close button the progress
bar and then
show test says creating a uh a unique
toaster and that's what i'm doing in the
javascript
there okay so that's the function called
show alert
show password okay this is what's being
called
when you click on let me open up
sign up
there is there you go so show keyword
okay
so this is the javascript function
that's being called and what it's doing
is if the type is password change it to
text
if not change it back to password just a
little toggle
okay we create a variable called temp
button text
so this is the text that's on a submit
button so it could be sign up sign in
so it kind of stores or this will be
used to store
what a button is currently named and
then you've got a custom form submit
post so when we submit a form
what it does it disables the button it
adds a spinner
and it saves the current text to this
element
and then when it's complete when the
form is submitted then everything's gone
well
it then we then call this so it's custom
form submit response
and what it does it removes the
attribute disabled and it adds the text
which it used to be so the idea is when
you submit a form
it's it adds a spinner saying loading
and then when the form submit in
it goes back to sign up that's all it's
doing and we just call custom
form submit post and custom form submit
response
when we call in ajax and then we've got
form controls
so we use strict but this is a variable
form controls and it's equals function
so this is kind of a general
javascript function that we're doing
here and
underneath here is when we in initiate
the form controls so it's a jquery
document ready
so when uh for when the html has been
rendered then we call the format
controls and we initiate them
so everything within here will win work
so format controls we've got a few forms
first one is user sign up we've got sign
in
user profile and we return and we in
initiate and function we initiate these
forms so each of them so that's how they
work
so we'll focus on one of them so these
we've got one of these for each of the
forms that we've created
okay so forms so we'll look at user
it's the user form which is the sign up
form right
yeah and we call
that in so we're looking sign up we look
at the form so sign up form
okay so that's what we're referencing
now this is what we're trying to
submit from the front end so this is us
submitting a form from the front end
processing
it in the back end and uh and then
changing the
page as necessary we're not reloading
because it's an ajax call
so this is the user signup form the form
so we create a variable form
let me make this a little bit easier for
you to see
yeah that's better so we create a
variable form
so that form is we use an ajax
function there so your little dollar
sign id
sign up form so the form is the sign up
form that is
in the sign up html this was one here
then we've got form dot submit function
so this is when we submit the form this
is what we do
we prevent default so if we click submit
on a html submit on an html form
it would just do its default function
which is to submit the form to the back
end
by adding event dot prevent default it
stops that from occurring so it kind of
completely stops that from happening and
then it goes through this piece of code
here
okay so we've got custom form submit
post
we're calling this remember we're adding
a little loader to the button
and then we've got uh google recaptcha
ready
so we have already loaded that in this
particular html document that's this
script here
so we can now access g recaptcha
so g recaptcha dot ready function so
then what we do
is g recapture.execute so we pass
through the
recaptcha site key that is passed
through at the bottom of this page
okay the action is
slash because this is the home page
right so this is the
index so dot then function so this is
the token this is the token that we get
from
g recaptcha the google recapture so
document.getelementbyid id token.value
so this is the value of the token equals
token so that hidden element
now has a value of the token and then we
submit that to the back end
so var form data equals 4
which is here serialize we call the
serialize function there
and then we call and we make an ajax
call okay
so the url is the form attribute action
look at the form attribute is the sign
up okay
main uh then our sorry method so the
form attribute method we've then got
post so this is a post
call um post request sorry
and then data we're passing through the
serialized
form data we've got a success method
and an error method so if anything goes
wrong right
we call the custom response or form
submit response so the button on the
form will go back to normal
then we'll show an alert which would be
error there was an error please try
again
and then we do a console log that will
only display if
default sorry debug is true okay if it's
false it won't show anything but this
will show an error if there is a problem
however if it's a success again we call
custom form submit
if the result equals success because
we're if you remember
in the logic in the view where we're
overwriting the
form valid function and
if we show sign up view
so if it's a success so if recaptcha
works then
respond with success if it doesn't then
we will call so it's a form invalid
we'll call the form
error method in the mixing
so if it's a success we'll redirect to
home page
if not we redirect false
we basically don't do anything sorry
then we what we do is we
call the show alert you can't really see
that can you
we show alert and we pass through the
result of the call the message
and then the result to lower case
and then with that we pass through the
redirect because we are
redirecting to the home page okay so
that
is the sign up form logic in javascript
this is how we're processing the form on
the front end
we're doing the same so the reason i
went through that in quite a lot of
detail is because we're using the
recaptcha
uh whereas these other forms we're not
okay so there's no gb capture at all
it's just basic we're getting the form
we're creating form data we're making an
ajax call with the
attributes action method and form data
we have got console.json we don't
necessarily need that that's for testing
so this is the sign in function the sign
in form submission
then we've got user profile okay
so this will be called when we
click programmatically the submit button
on
the form in root sorry
sorry it's in profile my apologies so
it's the form in profile
the profile form if you look the button
is disabled it you can't you can't
actually click the submit button
so what we do is we actually
programmatically click that submit
button
when we get the response from google so
we'll be submitting this form
in javascript from the
google where is it the in static from
one of these
probably google places api so when we
get the result back from google we will
then
remove the disabled attribute from the
form
button and then we will click the button
programmatically like i say
so it's there's no different nothing
fancy going on here they're all very
very similar
but they're the three forms and they are
in the main.js
so let's save that we've done the css
we've done the javascript
now we now need to focus our time on the
google maps google places and waypoints
okay now what we need to do is add the
javascript to the google maps
copy paste so let me
open that up a little bit okay so right
at the top of the page here
uh we call this so it's a get script and
we call
maps.googleapis.com we pass through the
google api key
and then at the end of that we plus and
this and
libraries equals places so this is the
call that you need to make to have
access to everything we need in google
maps
and this is what's going to be used to
render the map
in map.html so this will be the map with
the root
across the waypoints okay so
when done so once it's got that script
dot done then it does this function here
so it's google.maps.event add dom
listener
window load and then you initiate the
map
okay so this is just a standard get
script called for google apis
we've then gone init map function okay
so we have a variable of direction
service and
directions display and then a variable
of map so
we we make a new google maps and we're
looking for map route so this
is the element that i showed you in the
map html
so it's actually looking for this this
is where the map will be rendered
okay zoom is seven
i can't even remember what that means
and then we center the map against the
um latitude a and longitude a so that is
the start point so that is the center of
the map
and then directions display you set map
and you set the
variable map and then you calculate and
display roots so this is the direction
service
and directions display that we'll be
referencing in
this function down here called calculate
display route you've got some constants
so waypoints this is the c and d okay
stop over true
so this is how we're creating waypoints
and then we calculate the root using
this function here so we pass through
direction service and direction to
display
okay and that's what we're calling here
actually so when we calculate and
display root this
these are the two bits we're calling
which are here
so they're new straight from google maps
direction service so we're pulling them
through in here
direction service dot root origin is
origin
and they'll pass them through the
destination and waypoints these
are the variables that we pass through
if you remember to here
okay so origin destination and
the waypoints the constants here okay
that's what google requires to render
this map so
optimize waypoints equals true travel
mode
is driving and then we've got
function response status so if the
status is okay so if it works
then um directions display set
directions response
else fire off an alert okay
so that's how that works and that is the
google maps javascript
so we need to look at
google places api
and we'll paste that in there let's open
it up our wee little smidge
again we're doing another get script
same thing no difference
the only difference is rather than init
map we're using in it autocomplete which
is just a different service
okay so we let autocomplete so we have
that here
then we have an init autocomplete
function so autocomplete equals so we do
a new google.maps.place is autocomplete
and then we're looking for a um an
element
in the html which is id google address
so if we look
at profile
and it's here id google address so we're
looking for that element okay
types is address and component
restrictions so the country this is
where we pass through the base country
okay so this is settings dot base
country and this is currently set to uk
but if you set it
send it in settings.py to a different
country then it should
technically work okay so we have
autocomplete add listener
change of places so every time you
change the address in the input
it will autocomplete okay so on place
changed so if you click
the different address then it will run
through this piece of logic here
okay so the autocomplete this is as
you're typing it will change and predict
the addresses
but if you click the address it will run
through this code so you've got the
place so it's autocomplete get the place
geocoder you're doing some geocoding
there
this is why we enabled that api the
address so
again we're getting the value from the
input that we've just selected
and then we've got geocoder.geocode
pass through the address and then if the
status is okay
so if the address is fine then we get
the longitude latitude
from the response and we
add those to the elements that have the
id
of id underscore latitude and longitude
okay so those two inputs are now being
populated and then we go through this
logic
to get the street address to root the
postal code and everything else
and we add those to the corresponding
uh elements okay so i won't necessarily
need to go through them but
we're doing a for loop on a response
from google and we're
pulling through the street number the
route and saving it to the id
town the county country so on and so
forth
then we add the address
to we add the value to the id address
and then
we unhide all of the elements so
remember those everything with a hidden
element class
gets unhidden lastly
we fade in sorry i do apologize
um you find all of the hidden elements
and ignore the csr csrf token and then
you fade them in
so that's how that works i do apologize
and then what you do you get the profile
button you remove the attribute disabled
and then what you do is you um submit
the form
okay so we don't programmatically submit
the form we remove the disabled and then
the user can submit the form
that's how that works so okay google
places api js that is that
and then if we copy over the waypoints
quickly we'll just
fly through that
happy days right again another get
script difference being here it's
actually it's exactly the same as google
places api
okay very very very similar it's just
this is slightly different
because we are using this
javascript for four different inputs so
we've had to
manipulate the javascript slightly to
work so we
instead of google places apis js
where there is no auto fields i've just
got a b
c and d because we're just using four
waypoints
so again in it auto-complete so i won't
go through the logic of adding the
address and town and county to the
hidden elements
so we don't need to or getting a
longitudinal attitude but you will see
here that what we're doing
is we're going through a for loop of the
auto fields
and we're getting a and we're then
looking for
the um id google address and we're
appending the field so this then becomes
the if it's a it becomes the destination
sorry the origin if it's b it's way
point one if it's c
it's way point two and if it's d it's
the destination
so um this is the logic i had to put in
here
to um use the google api on four
different auto complete fields so that's
the in
init autocomplete and then we've got a
on place change
so again it's the same as google places
api
it's just i've had to adapt the logic to
work
through um and identify the correct
in uh element based on the field
from the auto fields okay so we're
passing through the a b c
or d and we're looking for id google
address adi okay so that's what i'm
doing
it's no no different massive no massive
uh
change to google places api js but then
we
called in calc root which is down here
so this is the function that we're
calling
and this is what we're using to create
the url
query okay so we're doing an encode uri
component so we what we're doing is when
we select those four waypoints
we end up creating a url parameter and
we append it to the url
and then we this is actually quite key
and then what we do is we call
window.locationassign and then we
redirect the user to the root url
sorry the map url and then we append the
query
so the query would be um
something like um
lat a
it'll be question mark start with a
question mark and it will be
lat a equals
57.4
and lats sorry long a
i hope this makes sense would equals
45.666312 whatever
and then it will be joined with a
bar and then you do another one and
another one and another one so the
parameter string will end up being quite
cumbersome
but it will be appended to the url and
the user is then assigned to the new url
with a parameter string
and then in the map
view so if we look at the main where are
we main views
you can see that we're actually trying
to pick up that parameter string so if
lat a
is found in request.get.get then we can
do something with it
so that's what we're trying to do in the
waypoints um
again this code is going to be in github
so you can have a good
look and make sure you know you're
familiar with it but
i hope that i've now gone through this
deep enough so that you
understand it without going too deep
that i've actually lost you
so i will end this section here
and in the next section we will test the
app and make sure it works
perfectly and that will be end of the
tutorial
so thanks for watching and i'll see you
in the next segment thank you bye
[Music]
hey everyone it's bobby from dick coding
here and in this section which is the
final section
i will be running through uh some
debugging
and just general testing of the
application to make sure it works as
planned so let's jump straight into it
if you look at my screen i've got my
command prompt open i've got my virtual
environment fired up and i'm in the
correct
directory so to the at this point if you
were to follow the tutorial on django
docs
uh you would have been making some of
these commands right at the start of the
project but
uh i haven't done them yet i haven't
done them for a reason actually
so um what i like to do is uh get my
teeth into a project and then start
making the migrations rather than doing
it right at the start
um it's just a personal preference
really so what we need to do
is we need to make a few commands
uh here so first and foremost we need to
make
migrations so python manage dot py
make migrations these will this will
make
some migration uh py files and a cache
of the model migrations and other bits
and pieces
if it will work
help if that was a full stop
okay so from human friendly import
format time span
no model names human friendly so
is that let me have a look quickly
i have a funny feeling that we need to
install
it is it's just called human friendly so
let's go
pip install human
friendly
brilliant make migrations
there we go that worked then what we'll
do is we will
migrate
so if we now open up sublime text you'll
see
that we have a few extra files in here
now so we've got db.sqlite3
so that's for the database so in users
we've now got a py
cache and in migrations we should have
there you go so you got initial
so if we were to make a change to the
model and then run migrations again
it would then essentially just create a
new file
and it will make it make a list of all
of the changes you're making and all of
the amendments so all of the creates and
updates and things like that
main won't have it will have the py
cache but migrations will be blank
because we don't have any models
okay so these are the migrations we made
you'd expect it to look like this so
we've got dependencies of the off user
model
which we have you know that's the
one-to-one field
and then you've got the id timestamp
date field
okay so that's what we've done by making
migrations
if we now run server
so python manage.py
run server hopefully we'll be able to
see what the project looks like
on our browser
so let's go
uh control shift n to open up an
incognito screen
just level that off a little bit and if
we go local host
we've port a thousand
wonderful i was hoping that was going to
look like that
so you can see here that it's gone sign
in
question mark next okay so
um the accounts page has uh redirected
us to sign in
okay so we haven't got an account so we
will sign
up ah there we go so object has no
attribute
recaptcha public key so
what have we done here so if we go back
into settings
all right okay so we'll call this
public key
let me have a look at my other project
to see what i did call it
so as we there we go so
and that one isn't secret key we need to
call that private key
so okay so that will now reset the
uh server i think that's now working and
if we go back this is
you see in the screen here because
you've got debug set to true if that was
set to false you won't be seeing it
there we have it right that's all now
working so this is the sign up page
okay so let's go bobby
stearman username
bobby at did coding.com
password let's go um
p word now let's go
password one two three four five
if i click show password it will show
that okay
one two three four five and the reason
is showing that's because i'm toggling
between
a password field and a text field okay
so let's click
sign up you can see here the fact that
we've got this recaptcha
element at the bottom of the screen
would suggest that it's actually working
so let's click
sign up oh it's too common so you need
to have a good password so let's go
let's go fred fred1
can't assume that's going to be very
there we go thank you for signing up so
the fact that come up with an error and
it come up with a message shows that the
form
errors actually work in the mixing which
is fantastic so now that we're signed in
we're now in the accounts page which is
the home page right
if we're not signed in it would just
redirect us to the sign in page
so uh the username is decoding using a
name is bobby stearman let's create a
profile
so this is the recap not the recapture
this is the google places
javascript so if i put one two three
oh okay that's not working okay that's
not working
inspect console
fail to load resource the server
responded with status of 404 so google
places.js
cannot be found okay interesting
so static google places
because it's not getting it's google
places
is that right is that what we're
referencing
and let's look at um no templates
and we'll look at profile and
what are we looking for here
google places javascript so that was a
mistake on my part okay
so this is all part of debugging so if
we refresh the page
that will now go because that file has
been changed the name has been changed
so if we now go one two three this page
cannot load maps correctly
do you own this website interesting
let me just debug this quickly
okay i figured out what it was it was
because i hadn't enabled billing on the
api and you have to do that for it to
work so
go ahead and do that on your api keys so
if i now go one two three
there you go and then we'll click
buckingham palace and then it will
unhide all of those hidden elements and
we'll click
update your profile has been updated
wonderful it should now there we go
brilliant so
user profile if we click to that you can
change the address
so it's create or um update which is
great we've then got
root so these are the four so this is
the start address waypoint
one two and destination let's see if
this works so
i'm going to go with
uh
okay i know that address going to go
with
one cherry orchard
there we go i would do another
i'll go one high street
stream there we go
no not that one one high street
stream i'll click on that one and lastly
we'll go
with uh one
marketplace ely uk
and now that i've completed all four
waypoints can you see
this so we've got map question mark then
we've got la a
and it's got long a that be long b
see how let's create that parameter
string that's what's being used
in the view okay so we go
into um the view in main
there we go so it's picking up all of
those from the
parameter string okay
so we've got start destination duration
distance direction that's about right to
be fair if you're going to do that
little route that's exactly how far
i'd expect it to be this is the map
sutton had them stretch them ealy
brilliant if we click on this will this
work happy
days and that's the directions
let's just double check the sign out
works there we go
so um site let's chuck sign in
as well so it's bobby did
coding.com and was it fred fred1
i think i used check show passwords
sign in you are now logged in everything
works to plan i'm over the moon so there
we have it there's your django app that
works with
two google api keys and six different
google apis
one of which is recaptcha and the others
are a whole bunch of maps apis
so we can do predictive addresses
we can use maps we can use waypoints
it's fantastic and it looks pretty good
as well
so you can find this code on my github
the github
repository link will be in the
description
thank you for watching and i will be
seeing you in the next tutorial thank
you bye